is
good morning
we'll get started this morning and uh
for those of you who are joining us in
in person we appreciate you braving the
elements uh
uh anybody that didn't make it out this
morning deterred by the one inch of snow
will never be welcome to another event
i'm just kidding
uh but uh we're we're grateful for your
uh you're coming out this morning we're
excited to have adam meyerson who has a
wealth of experience uh in academia in
the think tank community and now as
president of the philanthropy round
table will bring a much needed
perspective to the threats and
challenges facing
the long and wonderful record of
american generosity
i want to start off by making a couple
of announcements
my name is david bob i serve as director
of the allen p kirby junior center for
constitutional studies and citizenship
it's a washington dc based program of
hillsdale college it's a new program and
we're excited to having last month
broken ground for a rehabilitation
project
for a building that will stand
at the 300 block of massachusetts avenue
northeast so in constitution day 2010
just nine months from now we'll open
that building and be able to host
programs lectures like this one and a
number of other series that soon will be
launched we encourage you to check out
the kirby center uh online at the
kirbycenter.org
there you'll find a number of uh
announcements about upcoming programs
let me just give you a brief
sketch of a few things that are upcoming
this wednesday
at the washington court hotel not too
far from here congressman paul ryan who
has since 1998 represented the first
district of wisconsin will be speaking
on health care reform and progressivism
this is a national address you don't
want to miss because while
some are treating the
legislation under consideration as a
done deal congressman ryan and others
have a few things to say about that they
also
want to put that debate that we've had
in a larger context
and he will be addressing the the
context of progressivism
uh seeing the current administration as
sort of the third wave of progressives
what do they have in store with their
ideas of health care reform and how
should we understand that as citizens
so that's january 13th then on january
30th
in chantilly virginia we'll be offering
a first of its kind event for hillsdale
and perhaps something that with the
proliferation of town halls hasn't
happened very much in any of them and
that's to have a town hall a national
town hall
that focuses on the constitution
featuring hillsdale college faculty
including the president of the college
dr larry yarn the program will run uh a
full day in length it will go from nine
a.m to three p.m
there are
there's an audience that will be in
person but if you want to on that day
tune in online you'll be able to do so
and that's through the kirby center
website so check that out there's an
announcement about that program our next
lecture in this series on february 5th
friday features a assistant professor of
history from the college dr terence
moore
will speak on
the greatness of presidents washington
and lincoln and speak to how those two
men largely self-educated how they uh
became the statesman that they were
you know we celebrate presidents day
which this year happens to fall on
february 15th
but congress has never changed the
official designation of that day it
still is george washington's birthday
and that's what we're going to do is
take february 5th to celebrate just a
bit early
the birthday of george washington and
also
the birthday of the the man that most
admired george washington perhaps of any
of our presidents and most emulated him
abraham lincoln so that's our next first
principles talk
i also would like to draw your attention
to an event that's coming up on tuesday
january 19th and this is sponsored by
the virginia liberty project dr walter
williams known to many of you i'm sure
is going to speak
and celebrate american free enterprise
there's information about that upstairs
on the desk
it's now my pleasure to introduce to you
virginia thomas
who for the last year has been
instrumental in helping to launch the
kirby center
she
as usual has many uh things that that
she's involved in and and has an
exciting project that she now is
president of called liberty central
she's also on the board of directors of
the virginia liberty project having been
at the heritage foundation as uh head of
executive relations for uh for 10 years
uh we were thrilled at hillsdale to to
have her expertise and energy uh we're
grateful that she's uh continuing on
with the college as a counselor to the
president and uh please join me in
welcoming virginia thomas
i promise we're soon getting to adam
meyerson too thank you david um
i do want to mention the virginia
liberty project event and i'm so glad
that david mentioned it and that the
flyer is here but walter williams will
speak on tuesday night january 19th of
over at the waterford right off 66
in virginia the role of government in a
free society
liberty central is going to be a website
that comes up around the end of april
and it's going to be about online civic
education activism and community
building and i just was telling adam
meyerson part of it is going to feature
exciting charitable events that people
are doing around the country it's going
to have a real listening
post to the ground and we will be
talking and featuring things that people
are doing outside the scope of
government that are honorable charitable
exciting courageous
things that are happening in the
charitable community
so let me move on to adam meyerson who
joined the philanthropy roundtable nine
years ago as president when he left
heritage where i was and i had the
chance to work with him there
at the round table it's the largest
american association of foundations and
charitable givers preserve dedicated to
preserving and protecting donor intent
philanthropy uh philanthropic freedom
and the advancement of liberty
opportunity and personal responsibility
through charitable giving
from
1993 to 2001 he was at the heritage
foundation where he served as president
vice president for educational affairs
there and he was
involved in the publication of
items around the founding fathers around
the no excuses work in the school arena
as well as the editor-in-chief of
heritage's main magazine policy review
from 1983 to 1998.
before that he was with the wall street
journal
as editor of the manager's journal and
asia columns and he did book reviews for
them
he graduated from yale and he came very
close to a doctorate he's that close to
a doctorate in international
business today he will speak to us about
the attacks on the private charitable
sector in our country as we witness
various policies and initiatives that
end up giving special government
benefits to some charitable endeavors
through the politicization of charities
as well as
some tax
issues that end up threatening the
livelihood and the sustainability of
charitable endeavors please join me in
welcoming adam meyerson
well thank you jenny and david and good
morning ladies and gentlemen
thank you for braving braving the snow
i have very fond memories of ginny from
heritage and uh and also of david from
the pioneer institute and both
institutions of course
depend uh a great deal upon charitable
giving
uh and and
how many here let me ask how many here
are associated with hillsdale college
and uh do you all know about ransom dunn
ransom dino is is part of
what makes america great in 1853
ransom dunn who was a
young professor and preacher
set off on a two-year journey to raise
funds
for a young institution of learning in
michigan hillsdale college
ransom dunn would ride on horseback
for six thousand miles
through the farm communities of michigan
and wisconsin and minnesota
and all together he raised about 22 000
which would be the equivalent of about
hundred thousand dollars today
these were not rich people
instead he appealed to their highest
ideals
their aspirations
their religious principles
and their desire to create an
institution of learning in the upper
midwest
hillsdale was also an important center
of anti-slavery teaching
and so he appealed to the convictions
of free people who sought an end to this
great evil in our nation
third
the tradition of private generosity in
america has always been central to our
free society
voluntary donations from the farm
families of the midwest
made it possible for hillsdale to be an
independent institution
and this gave hillsdale
the freedom to challenge prevailing
cultural and political wisdom
following another private college
oberlin
hillsdale was the second american
college to grant four-year liberal arts
degrees to women
and founded at a time as as justice
thomas uh
uh observed uh in a speech at hillsdale
a few years ago founded at a time when
michigan's public schools were
officially segregated by race
hillsdale was also the first american
college
to prohibit in its charter any
discrimination on the basis of race
religion or sex
without the independence that comes from
private support
hillsdale would not have been able to
provide this leadership
and one of our central challenges
today is to be able to preserve such
independent institutions
throughout our society
the creation of hillsdale college
was similarly part of a larger
philanthropic movement
to create an educated citizenry
with the character and the knowledge to
govern themselves as a free people
in his book the americans
the late daniel borsten
former librarian of congress
wrote about the great age of college
creation in the 19th century
every town in our decentralized republic
wanted its own college
both to promote economic opportunity
and to encourage citizen leadership
borstin cites an amazing statistic
in 1880
the state of ohio
with three three million inhabitants had
20 uh had 37 colleges
by contrast england
with 23 million people
had four degree granting institutions
it was philanthropy that enabled
colleges across america to grow and to
flourish
and this tradition of private support
for higher education has continued even
into the 20th and 21st centuries
even with the growth of progressivism
and as government has assumed a much
greater funding role
through federal student loans and
scholarships
through scientific research grants and
through state appropriations
the growth of the modern research
university received an enormous boost
from philanthropists such as johns
hopkins
leland stanford
and james buchanan duke
philanthropy continues to protect the
independence of institutions such as
hillsdale
which enables them to survive and
prosper and flourish without government
support at all
and charitable giving hasn't helped to
create entire new fields of academic
study
we owe the field of law and economics
for example to the john m olin
foundation
the whitaker foundation
launched the launch the field of
biomedical engineering
which has been so important in providing
new limbs
for the wounded veterans of afghanistan
and iraq
and the john templeton foundation
is funding cutting-edge research
on great questions where science and
religion intersect
for instance the nature of time
or the origins of the universe
today americans voluntarily give over 30
billion dollars a year to support higher
education
and thanks in part to philanthropy
america has the best colleges and
universities in the world
even our great flagship state
universities
depend on private contributions for much
of their excellence
the university of virginia for for
instance
receives more revenue
from private gifts and endowment income
than it does from virginia state
appropriations
and at a time of state budget cuts
and the stifling impulses towards
sameness that come from bureaucratic
rules
public universities
from ut austin to uc san diego to george
mason across the river here
rely on private contributions
for many of their unique attributes and
distinctive achievements
i've dwelt at length on higher education
but i can make similar remarks
about museums and orchestras
hospitals and health clinics
churches and synagogues
refuges for animals
protection of habitat
youth programs such as scouting and
little league in boys and girls clubs
and big brother big sister
and grassroots problem solvers who help
the needy and how homeless and hel uh in
their neighborhoods
private charitable giving sustains all
of these institutions
and gives them the freedom to make their
own decisions
private charitable giving
is also at the heart and soul
of public discourse in our democracy
as i mentioned earlier public uh private
giving
makes possible our great think tanks
such as heritage but all across the
spectrum right left and center
name a great issue of public debate
today
climate change
the role of government in health care
financial markets regulations school
choice stem cell research same-sex
marriage drug legalization
on all these issues
private philanthropy enriches debate
by enabling organizations with diverse
viewpoints
to articulate and spread their message
charity and philanthropy are central to
american life
and they always have been
since the beginning of our republic
we usually hear about charity in the
media for example when there's a
terrible disaster
we heard for instance and we heard a lot
of after katrina
about the incredible outpouring of
private voluntary support
americans voluntarily reached into their
pocket and gave 6 billion dollars
to help
the the victims of katrina
but what got less attention
is that americans routinely give that
much to charity six billion dollars
every single week
last year
americans gave 300 billion dollars to
charity
to put that in perspective
that is almost twice what we spent on
consumer electronics equipment
that includes cell phones
dvd players ipods you name it
americans gave three much three times as
much to charity last year as we spent on
gambling
and americans gave ten times as much to
charity as we spent on professional
sports
all this is voluntary
america is by far
the most charitable country in the world
there is no other country that comes
close
i'd like to briefly discuss
three reasons why america is the most
charitable country on earth
to begin with
we're the most religious country
of any leading modern economy
and the single most important
determinant of charitable giving
is active religious faith and observance
americans who attend church or synagogue
or another form of worship once a week
give three times as much to charity
as a percentage of their income
as do those who rarely attend religious
services
one-third of all charitable giving about
a hundred billion dollars a year goes to
religion
and whether we are jewish protestant
catholic mormon muslim or some other
faith
we americans have the freedom to support
our own religious institutions and this
philanthropic freedom has been
intimately linked to our religious
liberty
but the giving of regular religious
worshipers is not limited to their own
churches and other houses of worship
they also give more to secular charities
than to those who never or rarely attend
religious services
a second reason america is so charitable
is because we respect the freedom and
the ability
of individuals and associations of
individuals to make a difference
americans don't wait for government
or for the local noblemen to solve our
problems
we find solutions ourselves
one of my favorite examples
is going to be the subject
of a forthcoming hollywood movie
the little red wagon
in 2004 after hurricane charley
a six-year-old boy in the tampa area
named zack bonner
wanted to help the children and families
who were left homeless by this
destructive storm
pulling his little red wagon
zach bonner
went door to door for four months
and he collected get this
27
truckloads
of supplies
such as tarps and water
for these families
you don't have to be rich to be a great
philanthropist in this country
the third reason america is so
charitable
is because philanthropy is such an
important part of our nation's business
culture
wealth creation and philanthropy
in america have always gone together
they are both reflections of the
creativity
and the can-do spirit of a free society
from ben franklin who founded the first
volunteer fire department
to andrew carnegie who brought public
libraries to communities across america
to bill gates who is seeking to
eradicate malaria
great business entrepreneurs in this
country have sought to be great
philanthropists
it's not just because they have the
money
it's because they have the leadership
the vision
the passion to innovate and to build
institutions
and the analytical skills to assess what
works
let me give you three brief examples
how many of you have read or are
familiar with john steinbeck's classic
novel the grapes of wrath
well as you know the the the exodus of
of farm families homeless farm families
from the great plains
in the aftermath
of the dust bowl
was one of the largest migrations and
greatest human tragedies in our history
well
thanks to the pioneering plant research
and outreach to farmers by the samuel
roberts noble foundation
founded by an ardmore oklahoma oil man
agriculture is thriving in oklahoma
today
and we don't have dust bowls anymore
that's philanthropy at work
when tom siebel
sold software giant siebel systems to
oracle
he decided to apply his business and
marketing skills to another cause
fighting the devastation caused by
crystal meth
thanks to the montana meth project which
he financed and created
teen meth abuse in montana
has fallen by 63 percent
in three years
now philanthropists in other states
are seeking to replicate these
extraordinary results if you want to be
inspired by how philanthropists can make
a difference take a look at
methproject.org
the late don fisher and his widow doris
were the philanthropic architects of the
kipp network
of 80 schools across the country where
low-income children excel
they were also the largest scale
supporters of teach for america
using the same principles that enabled
them to build the gap retail chain
the fishers built extraordinary
philanthropic brands
taking proven ideas to scale while
maintaining high standards
of quality control and excellence
these philanthropic achievements
have all been made possible by freedom
for over 200 years
americans have enjoyed the freedom to
decide where and how to give away our
own money
the freedom to explore
to dream to discover
the freedom to sustain cherished
institutions
or to create new ones
and this freedom has in turn been
central
to independent decision-making
throughout our society
this freedom to give
is now seriously threatened
and at the philanthropy roundtable
and our legislative armed the alliance
for charitable reform
we have been concerned
about three kinds of proposals
coming from capitol hill
from politicians of both parties
from the irs
from state governments and sometimes
from the charitable sector itself
the first
is one-size-fits-all governance and
regulatory proposals
that would limit the diversity and
independence of the philanthropic world
let me give you a couple recent examples
in 2003
elliot spitzer then attorney general of
new york
proposed a prohibition on foundations
with less than 20 million dollars in
assets
can you imagine that
classic case of regulation trying to
drive out new entrants his rationale
was that there were too many foundations
for regulatory authorities to monitor
and police
in 2004
the staff of the senate finance
committee proposed that tax-exempt
status for charities and foundations be
renewed every five years
and have to be contingent on
accreditation
now as all of you in higher education
know about uh
about accreditation this can be a great
tool by
by people who want to impose their own
views of political correctness on others
for instance thomas aquinas college
was almost denied accreditation the
creditors wanted to do this
because they did not approve of the
books that that they were reliving they
didn't approve of a great books
curriculum
they thought that was inappropriate for
a great
college of learning
in 2007
a top irs official gave a series of
speeches proposing that the irs evaluate
the effectiveness and the governance of
public charities and foundations
in our view the irs does not have the
competence to do that certainly does not
have the legal authority to do that
in 2008
the california state assembly
passed a bill requiring large
foundations
to disclose the racial ethnic and gender
composition of their own staffs and
boards as well as those of their vendors
and of their grantees
the primary advocate of this legislation
the green lining institute of berkeley
california
has been working to introduce similar
bills in other states across the country
and just two months ago
the congressional research service
published a report calling for a new
oversight agency for charities and
foundations
our second concern
is the growing argument that foundation
assets are quote public money
unquote
and that decisions about grant making
are therefore subject to political
control
this argument was made most recently
by a prominent member of congress javier
becerra
who referred to tax favored treatment of
charitable giving
as a 32 billion dollar earmark
and warned foundations
that members of congress have an
obligation
to ensure that philanthropic assets
advance the public good
we recently published a monograph
that took strong
issue with the public money argument
the monarch the monograph reviewed the
legal history
of tax favored treatment for charitable
giving
and showed conclusively
that foundations and other charitable
organizations
do not lose their private character
when they benefit from favorable tax
treatment
moreover as chief justice john marshall
stated in the dark dartmouth college
case of 1819
the grant of a state charter
does not render a non-profit corporation
and its assets subordinate to the state
foundations and other charities do have
public purposes
and they are subject to the parens
patriai
authority of the attorney general in
their states but this does not mean
that charitable organizations
must serve the same ends as government
or that government may duly unduly
intrude in their governance and other
decision making
now there are rules
for foundations and charities and
they're
good there's some very good rules and
there has been a historic
covenant
that has governed
foundations
foundations have to use
their assets
for genuinely charitable purposes
you cannot use foundation trustees
cannot use their
the funds to fund
their daughter's weddings
that's happened
and that's illegal
you can't use a foundation to support
your favorite political candidate
but so long as
they use their assets for charitable
purposes
and follow some basic disclosure rules
foundations always have and should
continue to have
wide discretion to choose where to give
away their money
and how to make their charitable
contributions
our third concern
is proposals that would restrict
what kind of giving is considered
charitable
there are growing numbers of proposals
that would limit the charitable
deduction say to direct help for racial
minorities and low-income families and
communities
those are great
charitable objectives to serve those
populations and some of the best charity
in the country is dedicated to serving
them
but we believe that government should
not be in the business of picking
winners and losers
in philanthropic giving
and the for the future of freedom in our
country
it is important
to protect
the charitable deduction for giving to
churches and synagogues
colleges and universities
hospitals medical research the arts
the environment and many other causes
that would not fall
under some of the narrow definitions
that are being proposed
the late milton friedman once wrote
freedom in economic arrangements is
itself a component of freedom broadly
understood
so economic freedom is an end in itself
economic freedom
is also an indispensable means toward
the achievement of political freedom
we can similarly say
to paraphrase
milton friedman
that freedom in philanthropic
arrangements
is itself a component of freedom
and that philanthropic freedom
is also
an indispensable means toward the
achievement of political freedom
if you would like more information about
the fight to protect philanthropic
freedom i invite you to visit the
website of our alliance for charitable
reform
it's ac acreform.com
i would also encourage each of us
to think about how we can make a
difference ourselves with our own
charitable contributions
following the example of zack bonner and
his little red wagon
and doris and don fisher who have opened
opportunity to thousands of children
and the generous midwestern farm
families who have enabled hillsdale
to secure its independence thank you
very much
did you yeah jenny
i'm so excited i think this was a great
talk thank you so much for putting that
time and thought into this presentation
i think it's really important two quick
questions adam and
i wonder if you have
some direction for us as far as when
taxes go up
does charitable giving go down because
you have less and less discretionary
income to give is there some place that
you have resources about that and
secondly when congress was so quick to
pass the national service act in march
that seems to prioritize by picking
winners and losers in washington they're
prioritizing which objectives seem
worthy of
more civic people to invest in could you
comment on both taxes and national
service act
sure
well we're
there let me look at the taxes issue in
in a number from a number of
perspectives
we were
by far the most uh the most charitable
country
long before there was a
a large uh
but long before there were high taxes in
this country and
and many of whether we're talking about
the great age of of
college creation or the creation of
hospitals
there were organizations called
charity
organization societies in in
many cities across the country where
where donors
donors
put enormous resources into helping the
needy
this exists some of this has dried up
in the age of a large welfare state and
high taxes
we still continue to be an
extraordinarily generous
generous people
for the last 60 years
charitable giving as a proportion of
national income has stayed about
constant
at about two percent
uh now during uh during the past year
and this could come up again uh this uh
this coming year
uh the white house and some key uh
democratic leaders in the congress
uh were pushing for limits on the
uh on the
limits on how much high income people
could deduct for their for their taxes
that would
that would restrict charitable giving
uh and we think this is a time to
encourage and incentivize charitable
giving not to discourage it
and so we were part of a larger
coalition
to fight that very strongly so far
so far we have prevailed
senator john thune has been a great
champion on this issue
uh but we think that because there there
are so many
uh
there are so many spending bills coming
up where where congress is looking for
opportunities to raise revenue that that
that the
what you might call the politics of
confiscation is setting in and there
will be efforts there are efforts to
take as much money as
uh as possible from the private sector
including this
uh on the question of of uh
service and
other efforts there's there's a social
innovation fund uh that
a white house social innovation fund of
about 50 million dollars
to fund the expansion of great
charitable organizations
i'd have to say that that this is
something that that uh presidents of
both parties in the the last two decades
have been pushing for
they've pushed for it for it so far on a
uh on a modest scale in a way that does
not harm
charitable giving that much if it were
to expand seriously
then i think we would have to
be concerned about what
alexis de tocqueville
warned about of the
what he called it i think the immense
tutulary power
that
that looks it's that the friendly
welfare state that looks tries to look
after us but in the process
saps citizen initiative and discourages
citizens from
from acting on their own
i think i think at the level that we
have now
it's
it's not uh it's not going to destroy
the great tradition of charity but if it
got much bigger it would be something
that we'd have to worry about a lot
yes
sir under uh elliot spencer's threshold
of the 20 million dollar foundation with
zach water under that threshold have
been allowed to go take his wagon around
to collect charitable contributions that
he's not appointed
well in that case let me let me just be
elliot spencer's idea was terrible but
it wasn't that terrible
that is to say zach was zach was not
this was not zach setting up his own
with his own money
uh
zach in this case was raising money from
others and then then um
then giving it but let me tell you why
the the um
why this uh uh proposal was so bad
most uh
most people and organizations when they
start out they start small
you know most people if they're building
a business you start small usually it's
because you have to start small but you
you start small you do your you learn
while doing
uh and if you look at at the great uh
great fortunes or great businesses that
that have been built i mean heritage
foundation did not start out huge
hillsdale college did not start out huge
you start out small
and you learn and you grow
and the same thing applies in
foundations
and many of the biggest and most
successful foundations today are ones
that started out small
elliot spitzer would not have allowed
them to learn and make experiments and
and and grow and i it's it's a it's a
terrible terrible idea he quickly had
the judgment to realize that it was a
terrible idea but the fact
that he proposed it
is an indication that there are serious
people
who are pushing for such ideas
and
just as we see in in the history of
economic regulation
there are a lot of established uh people
in the in the philanthropic world who
don't necessarily want much competition
yes david
you pointed to the necessity of a
certain threshold of regulation could
you describe a little bit more about how
that should look at what level uh
regulations especially for
uh say some of the things that recently
have been discussed i think the spitzer
thing like family foundations how they
can be regulated properly
we think
we think it's appropriate to have a few
basic rules and and the basic covenant
that i described which is
you have to use your your charitable
assets for genuinely charitable purposes
that's a
that's a good rule
uh we're comfortable with with for
instance disclosure requirements
that uh where you have to uh
you have to disclose as a foundation
where you give your money to
that helps to make sure that you're
giving your money to bonafide to
legitimate charitable organizations
but having said that
if you follow those rules then you
should be able to choose which
uh which uh organizations to give to
i will say interestingly and this this
is will come as no surprise to those who
are students of how government works
a tax is currently imposed upon
foundations to pay for the enforcement
uh of these laws
that tax now collects about 400 or 500
million dollars a year
to police the charitable sector
only a tiny proportion
of
that of those revenues are actually
spent on the enforcement
one of the arguments that we have made
is
before we go about creating
a whole set of new regulations for for
foundations and charities let's start
with enforcing the ones we've already
got
and many of the there are abuses uh
recently a uh
there was a story about a a foundation
in in california where
where the foundation gave money to uh
for medical research that was conducted
by
the owner of the foundation
that's
that's a kind of self-dealing which uh
which we should which is has no business
in the foundation world and and should
be
guarded against and
you read about it in the paper and it's
a big scandal but it's against current
law and it should be against current law
and we should
most of the abuses that exist in the
foundation world are violations of
current law
we don't think we need a lot of new laws
uh let's
let's start by more vigorous enforcement
of of the pretty good laws that we
already have
here we go
adam what uh
on the california
proposal
and two social engineers the politically
correct agenda by requiring
gender
race and
those kinds of
declarations about the composition of
charitable organizations
is that uh would that be done by the
legislature what are the chances of that
of that happening and does it take place
in other states
and what is there that
could stop it
well we uh as i said this legislation
passed the california assembly
it almost passed the california senate
and it was withdrawn
when a number of large foundations in
california
made their own
voluntary decision to
to achieve some of the objectives of the
of the legislation
we take the threat of this legislation
very seriously and as an organization we
have
actually engaged
legislative council in four separate
states
to
guard against this and we are also
going to be working in a number of
states this year working together with
with
alec the american legislative exchange
council
to
to introduce legislation of our own that
would guard against
uh undue regulation of foundations
yes ed what are the four states
the four states that that we where we
had council were
california
uh florida pennsylvania and colorado
but
we
there are other states that are
potentials in in all of those states we
we
became involved
because
we heard indications that that green
lining the green lining institute and
its allies
were pushing for similar legislation
i should mention that the the threat
here is not just legislative
in fact there's a non-legislative threat
that can be almost as serious
or perhaps even more serious
and that is
that political leaders will
threaten
foundations and other charitable givers
they will threaten them with harmful
legislation
and in the process say well
you know
they won't say this directly but they'll
have some of their favorite grantees in
the room at the same time that they say
that
there is a kind this this there are
there are some areas of the country
where this is a cost of doing if you're
in the business world sometimes you
i mean there are parts of the country
where you only
uh are allowed to do business if you
uh
help out some of the friends of of the
powers that be
philanthropy has fortunately i mean
that's a that's a violation of
everything we stand for as a country
and fortunately philanthropy has been
spared that but
we think the
you know there is a
one reason we are fighting on the
legislative front so
so strongly is not just to fight the
legislation itself but to
fight the use of the threat of
legislation
for essentially blackmail or shakedown
purposes
how much of a threat
is the realm of the bureaucrat within
the irs
conservative leading particularly
religious institutions personally i'm
aware of
borderline harassment
and uh really unjust
pursuits of complaints filed by enemies
of these organizations
that are very costly both particularly
in financial resources but also in time
what sort of pattern i guess threat
you see out there and
do you see a pattern of that
particularly towards conserving
religious organizations
i don't i don't know the the answer uh
in detail i think that so long as i
think that the dangers of the irs which
there are always some dangers that can
come from from the irs in in tax
enforcement
but those dangers
one reason we think that the irs should
stick to enforcing the tax laws and not
for instance looking at governance or
effectiveness
in
charitable organizations is
we think the irs has
will act more professionally and have
greater competence on the issue of
enforcing the tax laws than
than it would on those
on those subjects we're also
i mean one
one i mean there is an effort now to by
a number of organizations in the uh
in the charitable world itself to create
a new regulatory agency to take
enforcement away from the irs
and
to establish a new agency
we think that that would
open the invitation for greater
political abuse than exists in the irs
the irs on the whole there are some
exceptions but on the on the whole
it is a very
it is a professional organization and it
has a long culture of
among other things protecting the
privacy of those it's investigating
we don't we're not confident that the
same thing would would exist that that
same culture privacy would exist
with another regulatory agency
especially and by the way
that many of the calls are for a
self-regulatory agency
in which the industry itself would would
regulate itself
we think that is as dangerous
potentially dangerous as a government
regulatory agency itself
and uh
not necessarily
um
it's not necessarily going to to guard
against the abuses the financial
industry
is used
as a model the the sec has delegated to
a
has delegated to a self-regulatory body
the regulation of of much of the
financial industry
in many cases those
that
in many cases that self-regulatory body
i believe it's now called finra is as
uh as harmful to
um
it
poses the same regulatory problems as
the sec but it certainly has not
protected us against the abuses that
that we've seen in the
in the financial world
thank you very much thank you